so you never went with the Ron Popeil
spray joe/george the jumper is good it's
a three plenty of time left 645
remaining George feeling it George puts
it in from long range it's a 10 toy game
gonna be at the top of the list
Allen sticks a pair six minutes to play
in the fourth George
Paul George did what he drives ball was
tipped that stolen by Grant ahead for
George look out
Paul George the layup goes good thing
just for a easy look for the nets
it's a Baldwin but they only got off six
field bullets out
Paul George soaring high for the Thunder
Westbrook accelerating George gets
around Dinwiddie corkscrews it for the
bucket the lead is down to six
KC champ right now George tapped out
Adams George drives he's found a chance
at a three-point play
Reuter the triggerman gets it in for
Westbrook
one-point game Westbrook tosses George
[Applause]
[Music]
the Thunder go in front with three
seconds to play since play comes in to
Russell Westbrook and just a quick flip
there by Paul George over to the wing
knocks down the three-point shot for the
net so you still have 3.1 seconds left
but Paul George wide open on that
because both players had attack Russell
Westbrook with that handoff is Allen
Crabbe ends up closing out of them
Harper watching play comes in to Russell
Westbrook and just a quick flip there by
Paul George over to the wing Maxim the
three-point shot